le gouvernement legault nomme sophie
brochu à la tête d'hydro-québec c'est la
première femme à diriger la société
d'état elle entrera en poste lundi et va
succéder à éric martel qui a annoncé son
départ le 11 mars dernier pour devenir
pdg de bombardier se fit brochu a dirigé
énergie air de 2007 à 2010 9
dans un communiqué le premier ministre
du québec dit que le québec se relèvera
de la période très difficile que nous
vivons et je suis convaincu dit françois
legault qui avec madame brochu à sa tête
hydro québec jouera un rôle central dans
cette relance on retrouve par facetime
sophie brochu bonsoir madame brochu
michy fillon bonsoir félicitations
d'abord et avant tout merci beaucoup
il est clair j'imagine que en quittant
énergie revend les fêtes vous ne saviez
pas du tout que le poste chez hydro
québec allait s'ouvrir non pas du tout
c'était pas dans les plans l'âge
envisageait plusieurs mois de sabbatique
et de ressourcement
alors non c'était pas dans les cas la
pandémie non plus n'était pas dans les
cartes en effet est là quand on vous a
sollicité pour diriger hydro racontez
nous un peu comment ça s'est passé les
derniers jours aux dernières semaines
pour qu'on se retrouve là à annoncer
cette nouvelle ce soir écouter tous
souhaitent aller assez rapidement parce
que comme vous disiez j'étais pas du
tout dans cette posture mental là je
suis revenu d'europe il ya quelques
temps et peu après monsieur martel
annoncé son départ pour pour bombardier
et quelques jours plus tard sa mort
c'est ce qui apparaissait impossible
quelques temps avant le chamboulement de
l'économie mondiale il se trouve que je
siège au conseil d'administration d'une
banque
voyant souvenir voyant le poste chez
hydro québec
j'ai simplement levé la main et dit si
vous avez besoin de moi je suis prête à
servir
donc je vais vous que vo faire vos
services en fait c'est lié à une
conversation d'antan mais avec jacynthe
côté qui l'a la présidente du conseil
d'administration qui est une femme
formidable et très rapidement on a
discuté ensemble
elle l'a mené son processus avec son
conseil d'administration qui ont mené
lundi
aujourd'hui est-ce que vous avez par la
jacinthe côté la présidente du conseil
est ce que vous avez rencontré discuter
à tout le moins avec le premier ministre
le gauche jusqu'à maintenant de 7 autour
de cette nomination l'aude non non en
fait j'ai eu l'occasion de parler avec
monsieur legault dans le passé d'énergie
au québec des forces vives qu'on pouvait
mettre à contribution dans le cadre de
ce processus là c'est un processus qui a
été menée de bout en bout par le conseil
d'administration qui lui
jacinthe et enfonce en contact avec avec
le bureau du premier ministre
c'est le conseil que fait la
recommandation est donc est ce que tout
ça est allé très rapidement quand même
est-ce qu est-ce que quel est votre
mandat au telle est la mission ou est-ce
qu'on a exprimé des attentes
particulières à votre endroit
en fait les attentes ont été sont très
simples dans le contexte actuel on ne
sait pas de quoi demain sera fait ce
qu'on sait par ailleurs c'est qu'on a
entre entre nos mains des actifs
extraordinaire une énergie formidable un
levier économique qui a toujours joué un
grand rôle au québec et qui va être
interpellé comme jamais pour agir dans
le rebond économique de notre société
ce qu'on sait c'est qu'il va falloir
innovant âge il va falloir penser forts
et avoir beaucoup de coeur pour faire en
sorte qu hydro québec continue de jouer
son rôle pour tous les québécois et les
québécoises et qu'on ressorte de ça
encore plus fort que lorsqu'on est entré
le défi est immense mais l'opportunité
est extraordinaire lors le mandat comme
confie c'est fait le mieux avec tous
culture participe à plein au rebond
économique du québec hydro était déjà
dans un élan de partenariat avec un or
est américain il faut voir comment sera
capable de poursuivre dans cet élan là
et peut-être qui sait d'aller encore
plus loin il faudra travailler avec tout
le monde de manière très créative mais
va-t-on par exemple puisque vous ouvrir
la porte
repenser la stratégie d'exportation
compte tenu du fort ralentissement de
l'économie dans lequel nous sommes
engagés présentement mais ya pas de
devoir prendre acte 1 comme tout le
monde prend date
acte aujourd'hui de quel bois avec la
nouvelle réalité à très très court très
court moyen et plus long terme
alors me falloir se faire une tête des
besoins vous savez il ya des yeux départ
de tous les plans stratégiques de toutes
les organisations qui vont demeurer il
ya départ de certains plans stratégiques
qui vont devoir être modifiés et aux
dépens qui n'existaient pas qu'ils vont
exister demain parce que des
opportunités vont se présenter
et c'est avec cette posture mental là de
grande humilité mais de grande
détermination et de grandes innovations
et détenir d'agilité que les entreprises
vont se différencier
hydro québec avec tous ces hommes et ces
femmes est en mesure de faire ça comme
personne en abordant tous avec humilité
mais détermination
madame brochu l'ontario a annoncé la
semaine passée une réduction des
factures d'électricité des particuliers
des petites entreprises des agriculteurs
je vous pose tout de suite la question
parce qu'il ya quand même des des
milliers pour ne pas dire des millions
de personnes qui apprécierait une
réduction de la facture des ajustements
est ce que vous souhaitez faire la même
chose chez hydro-québec pour les
québécois écoutez vous comprendrez que
c'est beaucoup trop autour pour moi de
me commettre à quoi que ce soit ce que
je peux vous promettre ce que je peux me
commettre parce que je le sais c'est que
la direction d'hydro-québec tous
ensemble on veut regarder ce qui doit
être fait chez nous pour aider notre
équipe notre économie et nos québécois
je suis en train de prendre position ou
pas mais je vous dirais que en ontario
il part de loin parce que les prix de
l'électricité sont extraordinairement
élevé je vous dis pas qu'on n'a pas
besoin d'aidés notre économie si nos
clients ici mais disons que je tu ils
sont pas sortis ils sont pas sortis du
bois en termes de coûts d'électricité
donc ils ont là un levier pour changer
beaucoup la vie de leurs gens chez nous
on va regarder toutes les portes mais on
veut surtout s'attarder à faire le mieux
pour l'ensemble de nos sites web être la
première femme à diriger cette
importante société d'état ça signifie
quoi pour vous ça mais ça signifie en
fait je suis je suis d'une grande fierté
grande fierté pour notre société
québécoise monsieur fillion parce que si
suit à ce poste là oui si à cause de ce
que j'ai construit personnellement mais
c'est d'abord et avant tout parce qu'on
est rendu avec une société qui est rendu
et j'ai espoir qu'une jeune fille de 10
12 ans 15 enquêtes pas qu'ils voient ça
et que dans son subconscient sans savoir
elle sait maintenant que c'est possible
alors ça ça me fait ça et pour avoir
travaillé pendant toutes ces années avec
les flops et auprès de milliers de
femmes au québec qui sont en train de
développer leur plein potentiel
mais je me dis c'est un exemple de plus
c'est mes petites épaules à cette grande
roue l'heure est au plan énergétique et
au plan social suffit
en tout cas on a la chance avec facetime
et skype ces jours ci de voir
l'intérieur des maisons des gens ça a
l'air bien paisible chez vous mais vous
vous relancer quand même dans l'action
vous allez quitter ce ce lieu un peu
paisible merci bonne chance ce fibre
reçu pour me parler comme mon père
portez vous bien merci bien la prochaine